now many of you know that I did go to
Guantanamo Bay to entertain the troops
I saw you flashing your eyes I don't see
one that jokey's like yeah but folks I
came away with so much more than I'd
ever expected
now I know that many of you have an idea
in your head as to what Guantanamo Bay
is really like for years we have known
much of what America's government did in
the name of American values Speedy's
sleep deprivation stress positions
waterboarding the CIA put a handgun and
are running powerful next to the head of
a dead al Rahim are not sharing
Guantanamo Bay bob has become the anti
Statue of Liberty but what if I were to
tell you that Gitmo is more like this
can you tell us how you were treated at
Guantanamo Bay
so is that like is that like he will be
true is it like you know Beach rules
second we laughter like nine crabs on
the shoe jellyfish sting ray and we said
that's just way too much
I am NOT in a baseball ever
rocket infidels backyard I mean that's
classic stuff right there
what if I were to tell you that
Guantanamo Bay is the most efficiently
run community you'll find on any
seaboard and above all home to an
exemplary prison for terrorist detainees
now of course our troops can't tell you
that because they have to be hush-hush
about everything and despite how
mainstream media has demonized them
they're really just normal kids doing
their job we're here in the ice-cream
parlor in Guantanamo Bay with Brandon
and Travis I'm Shelley Waterman I'm here
with my husband who is a marine with Vic
Cisco three four security forces all of
that applies to me except my name is
Jackie salud
Mima and you know saying I just walk
around make sure the streets safe
the Gitmo with Marine Corps security
forces I work at the hospital in the
central tech second lieutenant army
captain Air Force Air Force captain
Claude Howard Little Rock Arkansas with
the brief I'm the OIC for then top
interpretive operations element here at
jtf Gitmo I work over at ice which is
the interrogation control element I'm a
stationed at Joint Task Force military
justice and a paralegal in the Navy take
care of military justice for the Navy
and Army and this year okay so in more
detail detail for the viewers at home
what exactly does that mean working as a
paralegal here for the Navy as a
paralegal we keep you know the
discipline up you know good conduct of
the Armed Forces you know to keep our
service members in line you know making
sure they're on their goals of you know
taking care of business you know
whatever armed force they're in wait you
mean to tell me that there are people on
hire just to make sure that prisoners
are treated fairly but the media has
told us that Gitmo is a legal no-man's
land because when you get in you can
never get out like you're held forever
in a time warp without even the
possibility of a trial when you take
into consideration that Gitmo once held
more than seven hundred and seventy nine
detainees and there are now only around
221 left it would seem that more people
are let free than actually detained
which is of course a shame as many of
them actually return to killing fellow
Americans Americans liberals remember
them the victims in all of this
it's important to remember that these
detainees are terrorists not prisoners
terrorists just like one of the 9/11
masterminds Khalid Sheikh Muhammad who
thanks to Obama is now enjoying an
all-expenses-paid trip to New York as he
awaits his American trial and even so
let's look at the treatment of some of
these detainees you know how about we
compare it to the treatment of prisoners
right here in Los Angeles County and for
the sake of argument let's start with
the maximum security level detainees the
worst of the worst even so these guys
get an additional two hours of rec time
compared to that of California state
prisoners and the cost for their
high-quality daily meals is nearly $50
compare that to the 245 allotted for a
Californian prisoner not to mention with
each meal they can pick from four
different dishes depending on whether
they're vegetarian toothless or have a
sensitive stomach Oh humanity now of
course the mid-level threat detainees
which account for most of the folks at
Gitmo get even more bells and giant loud
whistles not only do they have a
beautiful ocean view bountiful rec time
oftentimes video game privileges access
to language courses laptop classes and
other various life skills training
courses they also get their own
top-notch soccer field yes folks
terrorists are entitled to their right
to Bend It Like Beckham you know even
the prisoners hear these horror stories
of Gitmo show up see the soccer field
and think
and of course because our troops do such
a fabulous job unlike an American
prisons inmate on inmate violence isn't
really much of a problem at Gitmo though
really even if it was it's not like any
of these scumbags could really do much
damage
it'd be like watching two hobos fighting
over a sandwich sure it's kind of sad
but no one's powerful enough to land a
finisher also these prisoners have
access to better healthcare then well
than you if they hurt themselves
attacking the United States service
member they get to have an American
doctor sew them right back up as a
matter of fact before political outrage
the detainees were going to get the
swine flu vaccine before Americans
you're still thinking of this place as
nothing more than a torture chamber you
know maybe we should ship these guys to
American prison says I personally
believe that prison should be as
unpleasant as humanly possible let them
bring their prayer rugs and everything
they're already on their knees five
times a day well the write up let's let
them make a few new friends oh that's
right no American prisons want to take
them even Nancy Pelosi the strongest
advocate of closing Gitmo flat-out
refused to have them sent to her
district as a matter of fact the Gitmo
detainees have it so well that one of
the military's biggest problems is
keeping Cuban citizens from sneaking in
that's right folks these people would
rather be prisoners of Gitmo than
citizens of Cuba I mean these people are
probably just tired of living on a
government ration of six eggs six pounds
of rice and two pounds of fish a month
and I'm like Michael Moore tried to sell
you the Cubans face long health care
wait times because there's only one
physician for 400 Cubans now if all
Guantanamo Bay prisons were to have only
one doctor humans would still have
nearly twice as much of a chance of
being seen by them of course they also
live without internet nearly all without
a telephone or television these people
want to come to America more than
anything we are here outside of the
light house in I guess what is
considered a raft boneyard with some of
the more well known rafts that have been
recovered by Coast Guard here from
Cubans who've been wanting it the United
States craft admire the ingenuity they
just throw together anything
and they're you know they're going to
America the little guys are determined I
mean that camera could probably a life
raft it's pretty incredible these people
really want to get to the United States
I did some exhibit of rafts built by
American citizens trying to get to Cuba
for their health care as Michael Moore
kind of insinuated but I'm sure it's
around so we'll keep looking
sturdy and if they can't make it to
Miami Gitmo is a next best thing it's
like a little slice of America in Cuba
and as Americans we forget how enticing
that is to everybody else in the world
and we take it for granted bro what
about the torture tactics at Gitmo
Geneva Convention bra well I'm so glad
you asked because I just happen to have
a list of heightened interrogation
techniques right in front of me okay
we've got deception which is implying
that an interrogator is from another
country with reputation for harsh
treatment of detainees see to me that's
genius Hirai khalid see i tried being
nice but my buddy see he's from croatia
and they have a different set of rules
so good luck convincing a detainee that
interrogators might have mistaken him
for someone else
rapidfire questioning isolation
incentive a removal of incentive and of
course you've got your old good cop bad
cop routines and all the favorite
standbys our troops are not even allowed
to force them to stand for prolonged
periods of time or threaten them or
cover their heads during transportation
or interrogate them for up to 20 hours
force them to do calisthenics deprive
them of sleep or force them to shave one
of the last big mistreatment of a
detainee case was a soldier throwing
water on a detainee now it should be
noted that he only did someone reaction
to having a cocktail thrown at him oh I
almost forgot
a cocktail is basically a cup that a
detainee will fill with any bodily
excretion he can possibly fit into it
which he then throws at the men and
women of our military and now our troops
can't do a thing so it's become a bit of
a sport for these flam Watts now the man
who were tallied with a cup of purified
drinking water was quickly reprimanded
and removed from the island a similar
cocktail was recently thrown in a
California courtroom the perpetrator is
now serving 30 years how's that for a
different standard our troops are sent
to these frontlines with very little to
work with and
biggest crime of all is the fact that
I'm even able to read this list now that
this administration has made this list
public our enemies know exactly how far
we can go and what kind of crap for
which they can get the ACLU to sue and
the sad part is that the troops can't
even defend themselves publicly as
they've been federally muzzled going to
Guantanamo Bay was amazing and inspiring
because of the incredible job that these
troops do but also heartbreaking because
our president has referred to their
entire operation as nothing more than a
stain on America's standing in the world
their commander-in-chief condemning
Gitmo for his own political gain as by
default made them out to be monsters and
of course the media follows suit
planning all kinds of atrocities and
covering the supposed horror stories to
come out of this camp nearly none of
which are true and of course our
honorable service members can't do a
thing you don't think that hurts morale
the troops will tell you that all the
objectors to Guantanamo Bay who'd
actually taken the time to visit have
flipped 180 degrees on the issue
including congressmen and Senators but
much like Iraq before his campaign trail
Barack Obama has never set foot in
Guantanamo Bay see Obama has to justify
his closing of the camp so he has a
vested interest in making it look like a
hellhole and by default making our
troops look like torturous animals so in
light of all this I ask you what do you
think should go and Tana MoBay remain
open and if he supported closing it
before has any of this changed your mind
be sure to let me know personally this
is one of the most incredible
experiences of my life one that I'll
never forget I think one's Hannam obey
is not only a great prison
it's the perfect prison and our troops
are the ideal and only people for the
job to any of our honorable members of
the United States military watching this
thank you from the bottom of my heart
thank you and I want you to know that
there are people back home who love you
and truly appreciate everything that you